well guys The Hobbit is coming up very
soon and I'm pumped for it I've been
planning this for a long time I'm going
to review each Lord of the Rings film
before the Hobbit comes out a lot of you
guys have requested this for me it's
been something I've been wanting to do
for a while so let's get started with
the Fellowship of the Ring Lord of the
Rings the Fellowship of the Ring stars
Elijah Wood Ian McKellen Viggo Mortensen
Sean Astin Liv Tyler Hugo Weaving John
rhys-davies Orlando Bloom Sean Bean so
many people are in this movie it's such
a great cast as directed by Peter
Jackson let me give you a little
well-rounded view of my first encounter
with Laura the ring see for some reason
I just I missed it
when it came out in theaters I don't
know what it was I wasn't like seeing
every movie back then you know I was
like 14 years old and I didn't have a
lot of money and everything my friend
was like dude you have to watch this
movie and I was like Lord of the Rings
whatever man go play Dungeons & Dragons
I'll join you later because I'm going to
work like you but he was like dude just
sit down here and I'm going to play you
Fellowship of the Ring and you are going
to watch it with me and I remember just
like halfway through the movie I was
just like dude this is a really good
movie I had never seen a film so epic
just the scope of this first film and
the others in particular which I'll get
to later it blew me away
I was 14 and everything and I became
like this Lord of the Ring is not like I
wanted to read all the books I of course
went to all the movies later as they
came out in theaters I watched the
film's countlessly I got the VHS tapes
then they upgraded to DVD and now I have
the blu-rays and I was so impressed with
this first movie it tells the tale of
the Ring of Power it's a ring that when
you put it on you turn invisible but
anyone who has this ring suddenly gets
this sense of aura or power to them they
feel drawn to it they feel like they
need it like it's just part of them and
they can't live without it they start to
forget about everything else in life
it's just them and the ring and when it
comes into the hands of a little
ordinary hobbit named Frodo played by
Elijah Wood he embarks on a journey with
a group of people to try to take this
evil ring into Mordor to throw it into
the mountain of fire where it was
actually created it's the only place you
can destroy it the evil Sauron the
original owner of this ring wants it for
himself
now he's just like this glowing eye
who's controlling like all of
middle-earth and
these people he's controlling this
Wizard Saruman who used to be Gandalf's
friend and Gandalf is like the main
wizard this movie played by Ian McKellen
and this guy is awesome like Gandalf is
just one of the coolest characters he
reminds me a lot of the obi-wan Kenobi
of the Lord of the Rings and in some
sense I think Star Wars had some
definite Lord of the Rings blood in it
like for instance I kind of always
viewed Aragorn as like the Han Solo type
you know what I mean obviously these
books were written before Star Wars came
out I feel like Lord of the Rings may
have inspired George Lucas a little bit
see I just re-watched the whole trilogy
in preparation for this review one of
the things I notice right off the bat
besides how beautiful the film looks and
the amazing musical scored by Howard
Shore which is just mind-blowing is the
fact that the film is so just gleefully
happy at first it's almost sappy and I
just I love how they just they went for
it they created this world that this
looks so unbelievably happy and you're
just like this is this just this no this
is so fake it works so well
everyone in this movie all the actors
put themselves just out there like okay
fine whatever you want Peter Jackson
whatever the script says we're gonna do
it and we're going to make it as best as
we possibly can and it just it struck me
so much the absolute blind trust of so
many people with this movie first of all
the trust Peter Jackson with it someone
who I never handled an epic of this size
like you can just feel that it's a group
of people coming together going we're
going to make something special we're
going to make something extremely
awesome that's gonna stand the test of
time everyone's on their a game in this
movie Elijah Wood is excellent as Frodo
he evokes this youthful charm and this
bliss to him that is just absolutely
necessary for this character because
he's got to feel like someone who hasn't
experienced anything bad ever and he
gets these big wide eyes at the thought
of this ring and the evilness behind and
what he has to do and everything but he
has such a strong determination about
him too and Elijah Wood captured that so
well also what's great is his friend Sam
played by Sean Astin these guys together
it's kind of like the romance of Lord of
the Rings to be honest it's just so
sweet and caring and these guys they
love each other like there's times when
Sam's theme starts playing in the
background I like Sam you're so
beautiful as the characters embark on
this journey and they all come together
in this fellowship and you see all the
characters that are going to appear in
the
rest of the films come together into
their various spots of where they'll be
and how they're acting everything in
Legolas and Gimli and they're arguing
and Aragorn is just amazing badassery
he's just so awesome in this movie with
this sword and everything and throwing
this
I love Aragorn he's so cool he's one of
my favorite characters and Viggo
Mortensen plays him excellently III
adore everyone he's probably my favorite
character in the whole trilogy battle
sequences to the extent of these films
were not seen until this movie I mean
just up the ante for everything and it
was like Peter Jackson was actually able
to get some graphic moments like those
decapitations and stuff in this movie
there's a moment in this movie that just
blows my fanboy mind I remember when I
first saw it it's it's when after the
fellowship has all come together and you
get this great shot of all of them just
coming over this mountain it's this
first big shot this take of them and
they're all walking over this mountain
and Howard Shore theme is like blaring I
just remember sitting there like this is
so cool
I swear such a dork I really am I just
whatever I like being a dork Fellowship
of the Ring was like a modern-day Star
Wars it set up a great trilogy
introduced a whole bunch of new
characters it was epic in every possible
way and I loved it it of course gets an
A+ so stay tuned pretty soon I'm going
to be reviewing the two towers
eventually and Return of the King and my
hobbit screening is on December 11
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you like this then you can
click right here and get stuck my next
Oh